jumping in man um so I gotta ask the
most important question as a fan of your
work uh you have not done anything since
ambulance I don't even know what you're
doing next and as a fan I would like to
know what are you thinking about it's
taking a little time down I've prepped a
lot of docs I've gotten the doc doc
World documentaries and
um we're shooting some of those
currently right now the strike is put
put ruin on and in full hold on several
things that I'm working that uh one with
a big producer but I don't want to go
into all these different things uh can I
ask what the documentaries are that
you're working on one is about to sold
sold five shows of Discovery it's a
Serial killing family thank you thank
you okay yeah so uh
it's very uh it's a story you've not
heard before okay
it's uh yeah
um and uh
two over two others so sure one of the
things we have to talk about
Transformers I'm about to ask you but as
a fan I just want to know what you're
doing yeah so one of the things I heard
you were but I'm itching to shoot I'm
telling you I I really itching to shoot
and it's really
it's uh the strike needs to happen but
it's it's gonna be rough for a lot of
people I I fully agree so one of the
things you obviously are you've been so
involved in the Transformers since its
Inception uh can you talk a little bit
about because it yeah it was the exactly
I remember going to lunch saying I'd
like to do this Transformer movie
so I want to know with this film you you
have an expert eye with CGI and I would
imagine that your expertise can play in
on this one with looking at certain
visual effects shots and giving feedback
can you can you talk about that as much
yeah I I
I helped a lot I talked to the the
different teams different uh effects
teams and they had animators and
lighters and whatnot and giving them
tips and uh they asked a lot of
questions and through the process I
would would have different meetings so
uh
uh it's a machine it's a lot of people
it's uh and it's a mathematical machine
you gotta keep the machine moving you
know what was your take because this is
uh the first time I believe you have
like fur like there's a lot of visual
effects that were able to be used in
this film remember they invented fur on
other movies so uh
so that's true but I'm in in
Transformers but one of the things I
heard you visited the set in Peru when
they were shooting what what was that
like for you stepping on set I gotta
tell you let me just tell you when I was
when I visited that voice three it's
kind of sad I mean it's like this is
like it's
it's like you love other people doing it
but it's like oh you know but it but
it's it brings back a lot of memories
because this is like my baby one of my
babies and I've left two you know Bad
Boys was my first one and then you know
I didn't do the it's I did one or two
and then this one I won five movies uh
but you it's good to pass a torch and um
you know I've helped both directors that
have done uh the other movies
um
and I help uh just in terms of advising
on editing this loud and you know it
needs a lot of people when you do these
movies I've already been told I can't uh
we've got to end I'm just gonna say
let's do another q a in L.A
Armageddon or something I would love to
make it happen What do we do with the Q
a we get an ambulance okay and I I think
you had a good time had a great time
that's my boy